[Applause]
all right folks we're back danny aiello
coming up
eel's going to perform great show all
around but first ladies and gentlemen uh
from time to time
we here at late night feel the need to
remind ourselves
what is truly important in this life
isn't that right
that is exactly right conan and you know
there's no better way
to get this kind of message across than
with a fable
exactly good point andy so ladies and
gentlemen uh please welcome
mr nipsey russell as
that's right that's right as
there's more as he reads a story from
his very own book
nipsey's fables
thank you conan and the fable that i'm
presenting tonight is entitled
the turtle who thought he was a corn
muffin and
it goes like this once upon a time
on the shores of a freshwater pond
there lived a turtle who thought he was
a corn muffin
son you've been sitting in the nest all
day
why don't you go out and swim with the
other turtles
i am not a turtle i'm a corn muffin
did you hear that mother the boy thinks
he's a corn muffin
well he's the dangest looking corn
muffin i've ever seen
look i don't know who you are
or why i'm here but i can tell you this
from this day forth
i will spend every waking second of my
life
searching the globe for my real family
and so our little friend started
crawling
i can tell you he crawled around the
world
from the magical streams of trumpet
valley
through the yum yum trees on animal
mountain
and all the way over to gugu falls in
the flippity-flop hollow
and then one day just as he was about to
give up
he stumbled across dingle's bakery
[Music]
a tiny mom-and-pop place on a quiet
sunny street
and in there a great surprise awaited
our little friend
mama daddy oh
mama your skin it's still so
soft and pretty and daddy
daddy you're still holding down the fort
look at you and little ronnie you're not
so
little anymore oh i can't believe it
look at us a family oh
and just then into dingle's bakery
walked a tall dark and very handsome
[Music]
policeman
good morning i like a corn muffin please
this is no corn muffin this is a turtle
i'm telling you this is a turtle i asked
for a corn muffin
a corn muffin not a turtle this is a
turtle
and the moral of the fable is when you
go into a bakery
make sure it is not run by a stupid
good night thank you very much
terrific job thank you it's a beautiful
fable i hope we all learned something
we'll take a break we'll be right back
with danny aiello stick around